this is a curve representing lean muscle
mass gain on consuming 0.8 grams of
protein per kilogram body weight over a
period of 16 weeks
and this curve represents muscle gains
when the study group consumed 1.6 grams
of protein per kilogram body weight over
the same time frame this basically shows
that muscle gains were increased by more
than 50 percent when the protein intake
were doubled by the Baseline values
now to consume this much protein from
natural food sources you would have to
eat a lot of protein-rich foods daily
to put things into perspective to get
150 grams of protein you would have to
eat 12 egg whites 200 grams of chicken
breast 1 cup of Greek yogurt 100 grams
of salmon and 250 grams of cottage
cheese which is doable but eating so
much on a daily basis gets difficult for
most people
this is where the role of protein
supplements comes in especially whey
protein now if you're watching this
video you probably already consume whey
protein I mean that's why you're here
right you want to know more about this
protein powder that you consume so
passionately every day after hitting the
gym but have you ever wondered what is
whey protein and how is it made have you
ever thought about how whey protein
makes our muscles grow
hello and welcome to Med simplified I'm
Dr Umar Malik and in this video we'll
take a deep dive into the science of
whey protein we'll try to understand
what is whey protein how is it made and
why is it so important if you want to
gain muscle mass so whether you are a
beginner or a seasoned Pro this video
will take your knowledge about whey
protein to a whole Next Level so without
wasting your time any further let's
first try to understand how whey protein
is made while researching this topic I
discovered a fact that really surprised
me a lot
it takes 200 liters of milk to make just
1 kg of whey protein that's a lot of
milk
now milk is made of two main types of
proteins casein which doesn't dissolve
very well in water and Whey which
dissolves in water easily
when milk is processed to make cheese it
undergoes separation into two components
curds and liquid
the liquid left over from this process
contains whey protein this Liquid Gold
once processed further is transformed
into the whey protein powder we all know
and love
the production of whey protein can be
divided into five main phases
pasteurization separation filtration
drying and final processing
the Journey of making whey protein
begins with pasteurization of milk
pasteurization is a process by which all
the bacteria and other germs in the milk
are killed
milk is first heated to over 100 degrees
Celsius and then rapidly cooled to 4
degrees
like I told you earlier milk contains
two main types of proteins casein and
Whey usually they are in the ratio of 80
to 20 meaning 80 percent casein and 20
percent weight
during the separation phase the aim is
to separate casein from whey
to achieve this an enzyme known as
chymosin is added to the milk the casein
proteins in the milk are present in the
form of micelles which look something
like this
breaks the chemical bonds in these
micelles which destabilizes its
structure this causes clumping of these
micelles which aggregate together and
start to settle down at the bottom
the liquid part that is left on the top
is the one we are mainly concerned with
and it is none other than the whey
protein
this liquid is separated and sent to the
next stage of production which is phase
of filtration
basically the liquid way that we just
separated also contains other components
like carbohydrates fats and additional
solids which need to be filtered out so
as you get pure whey protein
now there are two main mechanisms that
are used for filtration membrane
filtration and iron Exchange let's
simplify these membrane filtration
process uses special membranes with
small pores to separate different
components in way based upon their size
depending upon the pore size of the
membranes we can have Micro filtration
ultra filtration and Nano filtration
when liquid whey is passed through the
micro filtration membranes most fat and
lactose from the liquid are removed and
the resulting product is the base of
whey protein concentrate
the process of ultra filtration is done
if whey protein isolate has to be
produced this removes all the lactose
and makes a protein content of the way
highly concentrated
Nano filtration reduces the mineral
content of the way especially sodium and
potassium chlorides
the filtration phase is crucial for
obtaining high quality whey products
with desired characteristics it removes
impurities concentrates valuable
components like proteins and achieves
the desired composition of whey
the other method used for filtration is
the iron exchange method in which the pH
levels of the liquid way are first
Changed by adding a chemical agent and
then different components of the way are
separated depending upon their surface
charge rather than their size
First Chemical agents such as
hydrochloric acid or sodium hydroxide
are added which adjusts the ph and the
electrical charge on the proteins making
them negatively or positively charged
the liquid way is then passed through a
tube-like structure which contains an
anionic membrane and a cationic membrane
the anion exchange membranes are
positively charged so all the negatively
charged proteins in the way like beta
lactoglobulin Alpha luct albumin and
Bovine serum albumin get attached to the
anionic membrane similarly the opposite
membrane is known as the cation exchange
membrane which is negatively charged and
attracts lactoferrin and lactoperoxyrase
since they are positively charged
proteins
if you don't understand all these names
don't worry yet we will discuss about
these sub-fractions of way later in this
video
so when the liquid way is passed through
this tube containing these iron
exchangers the protein sticks to these
membranes but the carbs and fats pass
through what is left in the end is a
product which is very high in protein
with little to no fats or carbs
iron exchange process is relatively
inexpensive as compared to membrane
filtration but it has its drawbacks
after filtration comes the next phase of
drying
the high protein liquid way is put into
an air dryer and under the influence of
hot and cold air the water is rapidly
removed after this we get the raw whey
protein powder which moves to the next
step of final processing where flavoring
agents and other nutrients are added
so this was how whey protein is made but
what makes whey protein truly remarkable
and unique let's dive into the
biochemistry of whey protein and try to
understand how it leads to muscle growth
and hypertrophy
way is a complex mixture of different
protein subtractions
each with its own unique properties and
functions
the main subtraction present in Whey
protein is beta lactoglobulin which
makes up about 50 of the total whey
protein content
beta lactoglobulin is easily digested
and contains all the essential amino
acids that are important for muscle
growth and repair
twenty percent of whey is composed of
alpha lacked albumin which is considered
a high quality protein due to its
essential amino acid content good
digestibility and absorption
Alpha lactalbumin contains a rich source
of essential amino acids including
lysine tryptophan and cysteine
it is particularly high in tryptophan an
amino acid that is a precursor to
serotonin which is the neurotransmitter
involved in mood regulation
Alpha lactalbumin possesses several
bioactive properties that also
contribute to its health benefits it is
known for its antimicrobial and Immunity
boosting effects supporting the body's
defense against infections it also
promotes gut health and has
anti-inflammatory properties
another subfraction present in way are
the immunoglobulins which are also known
as antibodies and they are crucial part
of the immune system
they make up a small percentage of whey
protein but are highly important for
their immune boosting properties bovine
serum albumin and glycomacropeptide are
some other subfractions present in Whey
protein
so this was about the biochemistry of
whey protein now let's look at how whey
protein acts in our body
so when we consume whey protein its
Journey Begins in our digestive system
it is rapidly digested and broken down
into individual amino acids
these amino acids are then absorbed into
the bloodstream where they are
transported to various tissues
throughout our body including the
muscles
once in the muscles the amino acids from
whey protein play a crucial role in
stimulating muscle protein synthesis
this process involves the creation of
new muscle proteins leading to muscle
repair and growth among all the
essential amino acids leucine plays a
key role in triggering muscle protein
synthesis and whey protein has a rich
content of leucine
leucine acts as a powerful signal for
muscle growth activating the mtor
pathway and initiating the process of
muscle protein synthesis in fact Studies
have shown that whey protein stimulates
muscle protein synthesis to a greater
extent compared to other protein sources
its rapid digestion and highlyucine
content makes it an optimal choice for
maximizing muscle growth intense
exercise leads to muscle damage at the
microscopic level and consuming whey
protein after a workout helps to provide
the necessary amino acids for muscle
repair and reduces muscle soreness
furthermore whey has a high biological
value meaning that it contains a
well-balanced profile of essential amino
acids that our bodies can effectively
utilize
in addition to its effects on muscle it
also influences setid and weight
management protein is known to be more
situating than carbohydrates or fats and
Whey with its high protein content
promotes feelings of fullness and
reduces overall calorie intake this can
be very beneficial for individuals
aiming to manage or lose weight
moreover it has been shown to have a
positive impact on metabolic Health as
well it can improve insulin sensitivity
which is crucial for regulating blood
sugar levels and preventing the
development of insulin resistance
now what are the most common questions
people have regarding whey protein is
when to consume it as it is a common
belief that whey protein should be taken
immediately after hitting the gym
however recent Studies have suggested
that the timing of protein intake may
not be as critical as once believed
Studies have shown that the body has a
prolonged period of high muscle protein
synthesis following a heavy workout
rather than a narrow window of
opportunity immediately after a workout
this means that as long as you are
meeting your overall daily protein needs
the timing of protein consumption is not
as crucial as previously thought
fixating on consuming protein within a
specific time frame it's more important
to focus on Distributing your protein
intake evenly throughout the day this
allows for a steady supply of amino
acids to be available for muscle repair
and growth
so rather than stressing about consuming
a protein shake immediately post workout
you can incorporate whey protein into
your daily routine as a part of balanced
meals and snacks
thanks for joining us on this
fascinating journey into the science of
whey protein I hope you liked the video
if you found this video helpful I humbly
request you to support our channel on
patreon.com medsimplified
we typically don't work with sponsors
but making these videos requires a lot
of research writing and animations which
all cost us money
so now you can help us improve our
content with just a small donation on
our patreon page as a token of
appreciation patreon offers exclusive
perks to our valued supporters such as
Early Access to videos behind the scenes
content and the opportunity to suggest
topics for future videos you can find
the link to our patreon page in the
description box down below
don't forget to hit that like button and
subscribe to our channel for more
scienceback Fitness content and as
always stay healthy stay curious